welcome everyone scale warriors are
engineers they're entrepreneurs
they're building they're doing things
that have never been done before they're
building things they're breaking
barriers they're pushing the limits of
scale
internet scale
internet of people scale internet of
things scale
um and so we're very happy to have a
very experienced audience here a panel
here to
kick off that discussion
on june
25th i believe
we will have don hatterley at our next
meetup where we will talk about what
happens when you start scaling and you
have all this data piling up and you've
got nosql and new sql databases so he
will lead that discussion but today i'm
very happy to welcome marie ann nemat
who's also an advisor for aerospike
marianne is an engineer and entrepreneur
she was founder of times 10
and until recently was running in memory
databases at oracle so we're very happy
to have her lead our panel today
marianne
thanks a lot modica
i would like to welcome all of you
thanks for joining us to uh the scale
warrior meetup i hope you've had a
chance to
talk to
other people and and to mingle
so we have uh
a topic that's very interesting to to uh
debate today
uh the topic
being the internet of things
so
the basic premise as you all know of the
internet of things is that
every device has the potential of having
an ip address and therefore being
able to communicate information about
itself over the internet
and able to receive
uh commands or or whatever
via the internet
so this is uh the
possibilities are endless
from uh being able to completely control
energy usage in a large building to uh
monitoring uh
traffic via sensors and being able to
pass that information on to uh gps's
and so on
uh some of these
possibilities have already
uh hit the market there is for example a
thermostat you can buy today from a
company
called nest
uh that thermostat will uh monitor all
the settings that you
that you change you might change the
settings in the evening before going to
bed or
in the morning when you get up or when
you come back home in the evening and so
on
and this thermostat will observe your
patterns and will automate the change of
the settings as as time goes on because
it's learning your your habits and your
patterns and it can
start figuring out your schedule and
learning as time goes on
uh you can also control the settings via
a mobile device or or a web interface in
general via
whatever device you is available to you
so anyway the the the internet of things
is already available
here
and we would like tonight to see
what the future holds for us
what
are going to be the requirements over
infrastructure be it
messaging or storage or data analysis
and so on
and um we have a very interesting panel
here because they
cover a broad spectrum of interests in
that space
so we have a panelist for example from
general electric and we know that
general electric has
home
home devices home machines
and they built that all the way to
jet sets
so their interest in devices is very
broad and varied
we have a representative from cisco and
all this communication of devices
is going to put a big strain on the
network and cisco obviously has a vested
interest in that area
we also have
two representatives from startups
in very interesting areas one is
an application area so quick pay
uh is in the area of monitoring space in
garages so they rely on sensors to
provide a very practical application
monitoring what's available in a garage
and then
finally we have
a representative from a startup on
infrastructure and that's real-time
scalable storage and data analysis
namely aerospike
so let me introduce the panelists
we
have sukanta ganguly
who is cto of quick pay this is the
company
the startup focused on
garage utilization
we have
shashank tiwari
who is a big data architect at ge global
research
we have brian bulkowski who is a founder
and cto of aerospike
and we have mahabubul alam
who is head of internet of things
platform and machine to machine
group at cisco
so
thank you for all the panelists for
being here
we have asked the panelists to
do a roughly 10-minute presentation each
on
uh how they envision the
internet of things to evolve
what it will mean
to us as consumers will it make our life
better or worse hopefully a lot better
what demands will it place on
infrastructure
and since we are very interested in data
management here a little bit more
emphasis on data management
and then finally what they see as the
absolute most important challenge
so we will start out i believe
with um
shashank is that the right name no
i'm very sorry
i
i think i got the i won the lottery so i
get to start
so uh thank you marianne i'm gonna stand
i i prefer standing and actually moving
so first of all thank you uh brian uh
for hosting this event and uh thank you
for all of you coming here it's a great
opportunity to connect with people who
bring different perspective i'm really
looking forward to more gaining from you
than rather telling you because i think
you all are bringing a very different
perspective which is outside in and
often we
in any company we look from inside out
and the world looks different
so it's the two sides of the coin and
also uh i did not prepare a presentation
uh
for this event it was thinking of a lot
of q a but
i did have i have many sets of
presentations i just pulled up one
uh that i will use as a back as a as a
background to help build the story
so how many of you
have
heard about cisco's play in internet of
things some show of hands
okay
how many of you we please be honest
because you know this is sorry
okay
how many of you think seriously that
it is something
cisco should be doing
okay
great that's that's pretty i i mean
at least 30 40 percent feels that
it's it's not obvious obviously uh it is
uh
yes we were
uh instrumental in building internet and
we like to see that we want to be
instrumental in building internet of
things
uh and
and so with that
my task in in in in cisco is not
about um doing it you know having a pie
in the sky but really turning that into
tangible revenue now
and in the near future so it's a steps
towards internet of things and even
though a lot of the use cases you will
see from different peoples will be
very forward looking but we have to take
incremental steps and we have to run a
pnl
ah to to run that business and so and i
will talk about
the use cases that we are seeing across
different industries and there is no
better example i can tell you like ge
they you know you look at that tv
commercial they're with a train talking
right
and and they have all kinds of things
and we do work very closely with with ge
on on many fronts
especially on iot so
what cisco did is um to um is
is we we started having machine to
machine internal things
and we struggled to find out where does
m2m end and where does internet of
things start and we had this uh
van diagram whether it was it was subset
superset what and and and then basically
uh we couldn't come to an answer
uh
re and and uh if you go to wikipedia or
anywhere you will not get a clear answer
what is m2m what is iot i mean they're
blur and they're probably 50 plus
definition for iot
so uh so we did a extensive studies to
see how serious should we take this and
then our our
internet business services group went
and did a extensive studies and they
came up with
a value that was so profound which was
machine to machine machine to people
people to machine which was which was
combining people and machine as well
even though we today we're going to talk
about internet of things which is really
around the things but there's also
interconnect and there's a huge value
between the machine and the people as
well
and so then we came up with this term
called internet of everything because
you know it was not only things it's not
people and so this diagram was kind of
the way that we said okay there is a
people there are things and there are
data generated and there are processes
and bringing them all together is kind
of our grand view of internet of
everything
though we will focus on the things
because we have a lot to do
99.2 percent of the things that
will be connected and not connected
that's the white space we have in front
of us
probably you are seeing it in your home
in the consumer electronics everything
connected from your xbox to
all your playstation to tvs and so on
and that is slowly moving towards the
industry
so the consumer electronics is the first
wave that is happening in home to make
your home life easy the second phase is
about the vertical industry so now you
you're seeing industries doing ge is
doing on their own shell will do on
their own and so will fleet management
companies so will every you know
qualcomm all join will have their own
people will start doing their own
vertical things i have a
nike fuel band has their own own
solution up there so they are all siloed
and they don't talk to each other
right but they're you know
is it internet of things or internet of
close things i don't know but you you i
i let you all decide but
but that is that itself will give a huge
value
for managing
reducing truck roll
it will be either around opex reduction
or generating new revenue or creating
new business models i will talk about
some of those
and then the far future will be some
something like a connected society
which is people thinks everything will
will interact with each other and then
it could be a web as as the as the
equalizer doesn't matter how you came
through through rfid
or through zigbee or through m2a
cellular
how you came somehow the information
resides somewhere into a web which is a
equalizer and then you have semantic web
that could be
a way to interconnect and create a
social network of things and people
and data and then as that progresses
that part of the web will uh that that
cloud solution will push down towards
the devices so you will see a migration
of some of the intelligence that's
sitting over there in the cloud will
move closer to the edge of the network
because the amount of data that will be
generating
no network will be able to support it
so we have to think about architecture
and so that's how some of the challenges
of cisco's comes into play
so this this market was evaluated to be
14.4 trillion dollars
and and it is we have a report out there
so you can search google and do an
internet of everything cisco report and
you'll find the detailed what we call
value at stake which is creating new
revenue opportunity or reducing the cost
of the existing and add those two
together we call it the value at stake
and that's 14.4 trillion dollar and
that's
and basically from cisco perspective we
are a networking company and we have
aspiration
uh to bring the some of this know-how
into the internet of world obviously
security is one thing that is that i'm
not which you should all take it for
granted security is pervasive there is
no single point in the network that you
say or security resides in the device or
on the network or on on the information
or in the cloud it's pervasive is cross
layer so security is very important and
and and it's not the i.t security it is
the iot security there are differences
between it
enterprise i.t or the i.t security that
we know versus unintelligent device low
compu low power low computation
and so on so there are other security
challenges that we are working through
but the four pillars that we have and
this is the key takeaway i wanna
and and this is how i will build up the
four cisco pillars on which we will
build our internet of things solutions
are around sensors and devices
network and protocols
data analytics and control system
in fact control system is the key
differentiator for the way we will look
at internet of things rather than many
of the others there are a lot of over
the cloud solutions and it's best effort
there is no loop back mechanism how do
you actuate how do how does it learn how
does machine makes decision
may and and working around that control
is going to be maybe you will call it an
internet of things 2.0
because 1.0 is what what we are seeing
already right it's it's in full play so
and then that will cut across some of
the verticals so we also looked at which
verticals ah are really poised to take
off so we have mapped verticals and sub
verticals into kind of
the chasm the jeffrey morse crossing the
chasm and he said okay you know
telematics is almost there healthcare
has imminent you know so it's ready
aviation is somewhere over there
transportation uh is so we mapped it and
and that allows us to have a different
go to market approach whether it is
incubation led something that we need to
handhold one or two customer do a trial
before we understand how to uh
productize it and how to replicate some
things will be services led something
will be consultative led some things
will be partner led so there are
different uh cells motion that goes into
based on the
way it is built so
this is a very simple these are some of
the practical examples where we are
making money today cisco's internet of
things business
is already somewhere over 300 million
dollars and purely
based on our switches and routers and
access points these are hardened
switches
hardened routers and hardened access
points they are going into
manufacturing plants they are going into
the pole tops
like in i will talk about in bc hydro or
2 million
itron sensors and we have our ip stack
in there and then we are able to collect
and manage and do all those things this
is an example that something goes wrong
this is the end full cycle uh some
something goes wrong we have to
integrate it with the back end of the of
the system then it's going to say you
know auto replenishment so replace that
that has to trigger someone's cell phone
and say okay that's sitting somewhere in
the warehouse number that go get that
and then ship it over there
that's the whole cycle has to be taken
care so it's not only the technology
part but it's also the integration
system integration and also building a
workflow around it similar in the home
these are these are today's example
today how you make money today i know we
think of a lot of fancy but
these money
how we are able to make a lot of money
today because our focus is really on b2b
this is very important
we segmented the internet of things into
b to c
b to b b to b to c now b to c when you
face a consumer there are different
benefits and how you get money from them
is a different versus helping someone
like ge to help automate their their
aviation or
rail and them and and the and the and
the
business there is a totally different
ball game so our focus of cisco's going
from our traditional franchise
enterprise customer is to focus on b2b
though we do have some aspect with sp
where we are going to b2c but we have a
different business model
so this is around a house which has this
electric meter and and these are like
two millions of those out there
the the power goes down
pole top pole top router it's uh it is
able to it's not only connecting those
on the field area network protocol but
it also has some analytics
and it sends only the data that is
relevant so it's not pumping everything
to the to the cloud
so it's sending back to the knock
and and automatically you know dispatch
is sent and a message is sent to the
home that your power is out
and and power gets restored
and you get a message you're back so you
don't have to call the future is that
you don't have to call
uh that i am out of power they they will
proactively reach out to you they will
dispatch it just like you have with uh
with uh with car right when you have a
crash you have those automated solution
like you know they dispatch the medical
they know the gps location and they're
talking to you so similar things are are
also coming into this these are very
very simple things and now imagine scale
scale is very important
so it internet of things is not as in
enterprise
or traditional i t because we are
talking about scale which is 10x 100x of
of of human
timing is very important
we talked about we we heard about real
time decision making
there are two types of in b2c you have
you have human machine human level
decision making so for a human if you're
doing a parking meter or
or that space i'm sure if i get my
response in one second that your your
space is reserved i think it's real time
would you agree
one time one second if you get your
parking meter you you reserve a parking
and you get back in a machine world that
is a lifetime
machines
have to make decisions in hundreds of
milliseconds they depend on each other
imagine a cooker robotics which is
cutting through and you put your hand
over there well you know you have to
have that kind of response time so it's
about real time it's about scale it's
about decision making control loop
loopback it's not one way just sending
it over there and don't know what it is
so the control over there and also you
will see that the ecosystem partners
will play a key role i'll just quickly
uh use the last few minutes uh just to
show the
the objectives of our of of our
connectivity platform is about managing
private and public networks because we
have many private networks which is in
the utilities and so on but public
networks as well we have to enable
service provider for mtm services it's
connecting things which are intelligent
and unintelligent secure info
infrastructure and compute data in
motion
compute data in motion is basically data
that is going at this moment flying
through how do you make an impact here
and now
one of the example that i we can talk
about is i will not name the service
provider but
over the top players
like skype when you do skype on on your
cellular network sometimes you will see
your quality of video or voice is going
down have you experienced that
okay
so what does what does what does data in
motion can do the people who are
providing infrastructure we are
providing ability for them to understand
that the quality is going down
instantaneously they can push an
not an ad but a message to you are you
ready to pay 30 cents to get your
bandwidth
additional bandwidth and you you hadn't
made no contract at that moment that
instant gratification has huge money
at that moment you decide if if i'm
talking to my mom
and i'm doing this video i will press
that 50 cent or 30 cent whatever
and and so so a lot of those are data in
motion so the real time aspect of a data
is very very important
and last but not least build a platform
where other people can build on top of
it they should be able to build
businesses on top of it so i think i
have taken more than my fair share of uh
of 10 minutes i look forward to a lot of
interaction i i look forward to um you
know uh healthy debate and we don't have
to agree
but you know let's go away from
having to know something about each
other as well as learning something new
from each other thank you
thank you
mahmoud we should
hear next from brian
hi i'm brian bulkowski from aerospike
and i will stick to my 10 minutes so we
can cause i'm really interested in the
question and answer quite frankly that's
that's my favorite part of this program
these programs so uh obligatory picture
of a rocket we're aerospike and where
database company and the aerospike is a
small tip at the top of a rocket and you
size it for the speed and shape of the
rocket creates a sound barrier breaking
compression wave if you don't get that
exactly right the rocket will fall over
i won't be able to break the sound
barrier properly so that was one of the
innovations i think this is a minuteman
iii
so we like to also think that we're a
small piece of technology that makes a
huge difference and scale
when i founded the company we were
looking at the problems of
advertising in particular but also media
in general of building a big data
platform and building a database that
could work at the kind of yahoo front
page scale that was prevalent in uh you
know five or six years ago
so our interest in internet of things is
uh we've been dealing with what we call
the internet of people
in that all of the behavior that is
happening on the internet that is being
tracked and shared for uh social
analysis sentiment analysis
and behavioral analysis in advertising
search retargeting all of that has been
our customers that we've deployed with
with aerospike
so in taking that technology forward
and thinking about um you know where the
next sources of data and where the next
issues with scale are going to be
we're dealing with customers who are
already dealing with a million 2 million
3 million requests per second out of
their database clusters and need to have
full levels of reliability
internet of things came to mind as a
good next step for our database so what
we've seen in our customer base is that
these internet enterprises the social
media companies the advertising
companies
the traditional enterprises are starting
to understand the power of the
technology that's being brought to bear
within advertising and social media and
trying to bring that into their business
now some of them uh like let's take uh
sort of the industrial control case we
were just talking about uh i was at a uh
a bay area car company you might be able
to guess who that is and um yeah as you
know they they recently won the award
for the most high quality car that has
ever been created
right how did they do that they did that
through data analysis
there's a lot of process and and smarts
to what they did but those cars are
throwing off a huge amount of data and
they figured out that that was a key
competitive differentiator years ago so
they've got these piles of data for
every spring in the car stressed members
stress analysis uh how the thing and
throwing off this huge amount of data to
me that's a great example of where we're
going going to get to with internet of
things once you can do these kind of
process analysis we'll see that even in
these silos that we have today so in the
internet of uh people analysis at first
we saw
people would just track on a website
right that's what you do you look at
your website you do some a b testing
that was sort of the first phase the
second thing we saw was that
personalized content finding my friends
information on my website the third has
been the sharing of information site to
site location silo to silo about
behavior search terms and targeting
happening at scale today within the
social media companies
so the ad platforms have been leading
the way at scale right now uh in a lot
of the uh um
it's still machine to machine right
because you've got a a set of servers
tracking your behavior looking at
networks i've talked to folks who are
doing analysis for example they have
contracts with carriers and so that they
can get randomized samples of what's
happening within carriers networks
without doing any anything specific to a
user right just knowing one cell phone
tower is hot right now and guess what
there's a whole bunch of the phones have
a certain velocity without knowing whose
they are
what can you do with that amount of data
right that's already happening within
the advertisement and social communities
so
oh it's
great um
i'm going to skip forward a little bit
so what we've seen within the uh the
communities in advertising today from a
database perspective is uh factors that
we expect will also be required within
the kind of architectures that the
gentleman from cisco is talking about
uh in particular the kind of
architectures that we see are really
three different data pools that exist
um there's always going to be hadoop on
the back end right that's what that that
really is the lingua franca uh but we
also see within our customers uh
different technology stacks for
different query patterns so hadoop isn't
good for everything it's good for those
a lot of those big workloads but there
are other query optimized databases
vertica's good for certain queries um
you've got a whole bunch of different
systems most of our customers have a
plethora of back-end warehouse
technologies but hadoop is their
database of record for the kinds of
behaviors we're talking about that are
internet of things internet of people
related
the second tier a mid-tier right now is
those hadoop systems once they get big
once they get past 10
10 petabytes to 100 petabytes
as a single system they get kind of slow
because the ability to segment and index
that data that's not what hadoop's good
at right hadoop is good at huge table
scans so within the big warehouses you
still have queries and
batch jobs required that are going to
take two to three weeks
and that's why when i was talking to
that particular car company that's one
of their challenges right now is that
they've got two to three week queries
and you know talk about the difference
between milliseconds and seconds you
talk about you know you just want to ask
a basic question uh how often has this
part failed in conjunction with certain
different kinds of road actions uh well
if it takes you three weeks to answer
one question you're going to have a hard
time doing research so we're starting to
see a mid-tier that is also an analytics
tier that is sort of second to minute
query oriented and it's focusing on uh
ad hoc research queries as well as
focusing on uh sort of short interactive
queries where you might ask a question
even as an end user not just as an
analyst you might be populating a
real-time dashboard for example on the
very front side is really where you have
real-time requests come in where is my
nearest parking space
an alert that says you need to now turn
down your thermostat or it will be
turned down for you or you know that the
case i'm sorry that was kind of creepy
with the getting an ad saying uh with
the bandwidth
i'm not looking forward to that world
i'm sorry
um but uh you know that kind of
real-time event so what we see at a data
layer is really uh the world is now
segregating out into three portions and
at aerospike we've really specialized in
the very front edge of that with user
profile user profile analytics for the
silos that exist today
and really are looking forward to the
world where there's a lot more
connectivity and a lot more internet
erasation of this simply because the pi
will grow there'll be more data to
process and more great business analysis
that come out of it
so
thank you
thank you brian
shashank tiwari from ge
so ge as uh many of you may know is
actually a company that is very old it's
uh
probably if you add up the sums of all
the companies out here it might still
stay older than that right so so it's
really really really old so just for
statistics sake it's the only company
that's still in the original dow out of
the dow 30 that was made every other
company is out this is the only company
that's remained it's a company that
started with you know a sort of world
war one era went through the great
depression world war ii so on so forth
technology evolution and now right so
now why i'm saying that is because uh
it's important to understand that this
is a company
you know as you're obviously an old
company you have a lot of baggage so to
speak right and you're a company which
has its roots not even the digital but
in the analog world right because things
started out then but having said that
what ge realizes is that the future
really
is in the industrial internet or the
internet of things and which is why it
becomes so important to understand that
the company which has been there for so
long which is really like as old and as
you know um sort of archaic so to speak
is kind of looking forward in the future
and investing actively to make that
happen so you know that's the important
point important takeaway there um in
order to do that g actually set up a
completely new center in the bay area ge
was never there so to speak as a
independent entity in the bay area
and so they set up a big center which is
you know part of the g's global research
centers uh it's actually in the east bay
in san ramon just you know an exit off
pleasanton if some of you guys know uh
it's a big center which is uh you know
there's a plan to make it
uh a few thousand people you know
depending on how you know how many
people are required to get things going
now ah an important point
in this whole investment and this whole
story and trying to get people together
and build this platform
is essentially to see
uh you know whether we can make this
happen so let me kind of
start moving and see what is this that
we are trying to make happen right what
is it that we are talking about uh sorry
um and some of these you know i'm not
going to really go through the slides i
mean this is just really for context but
the important point here is that you
know the technology evolution has been
pretty rapid in the last few years right
so
let me just um you know we have a mixed
crowd here so that's good but you know
many times i go to meetups and i start
talking about technology and people
start looking at each other because some
of those technologies didn't exist when
those people who were in the crowd uh
you know where started out with
technology because there's a very very
very young crowd so to speak
right but uh that's not totally true
about this
you know meet up here so you guys were
just kind of roll back 10 years not even
that far back i'm not talking about the
reflection way back you know through
your childhood or something but just go
back 10 years and you've seen in 10
years we have really rapidly progressed
through a lot of different technologies
right
so today is what this is 2013 2003
um google was barely known i mean you
know it was there as a search engine it
had proven to be like a great search
engine it was hardly there though not in
the scale that we know of today uh
iphone was not there in 2003. this
device wasn't born in 2003. right
we didn't have many of these things you
know things that exist in your cars
today most of you drove to this part you
know most of many of you have very easy
access to gps 2003 getting hold of a gps
was pretty hard i don't know how many of
you guys tried using you know gps
technologies of that day right
uh right now you can use gps on the same
device the phone you don't even need a
separate device right using google maps
and navigation right it's as simple as
that so all i'm trying to say is that
things have moved very fast and what has
happened is that all the excitement that
has happened in the consumer world has
sort of woken up the industry so to
speak like everyone's now looking at the
consumer world and saying well you know
a lot of interesting things are
happening and they can be brought back
to the
good old world of business and you know
exciting things can be done there and
that's basically the inspiration and
that's also one of the things which you
know companies like ge which are you
know sort of so to speak old school are
looking at saying well what can we do as
a
uh you know large industrial
conglomerate in terms of all these
exciting things that are happening in
the consumer way excuse me how can we do
it in the business world right now um i
don't know how many of you guys know but
ge really is a very diversified company
so
we are in all kinds of businesses so to
speak we are certainly a home business
as you said you know lots of things like
from dishwashers to electric bulbs to
things like those that we make right
but that's a very small part of the
whole gs business that's just one which
is more visible because it's in our
homes and we see that little logo there
right so we kind of recognize and
associate with it but
i don't know how many of you guys know
but we are like the leaders in the whole
jet engine category for example so a
majority over 50 60 percent of any
airline that you fly in the us
is probably powered by one of the jet
engines that made by ge just as an
example uh
and we go not only just with commercial
jets but fighter jets uh you know many
of the rocket parts stuff like that
right so people have been in that
business for a long time we also have a
substantial stake in the energy business
so we have things like wind turbines to
regular energy management to uh you know
a lot of thermal based energy
from generation to distribution to a lot
of those kinds of businesses right
we are big in the water distribution
segment ah transportation things like
rails right ah we are also pretty big in
um many other segments like you know oil
and gas exploration segment um
you know and a whole lot of others i
mean there is a lot of the industrial
segments so to speak industrial
automation let's just put it that way so
now why i'm saying that that's important
is that all of those segments uh heavily
depend on automated complex smart
machines healthcare of course i forgot
to mention that healthcare is another
huge segment right so in fact most of
the leading machines from ct scans to
uh you know just about radiographic
machines there are a lot of those are
manufactured by ge right
so all of those machines today are
essentially smart machines let's put it
that way right now why what i mean by
spark machines is that each of those
machines have not one not two not three
but a ton of sensors in them for example
let me just ask you a question just take
a guess how many sensors are there in a
jet engine uh you know that powers one
of let's say uh uh you know a flight up
there just take a guess
yeah it's it's in that range you're
absolutely right there's thousands of
sensors right so just think of it that
way it's not one it's not too it's like
5 000 per project engine and there are
like two engines in most planes and some
have like more engines and if you look
at a fleet right there are how many
flights are there in the united states
every day there are
not hundreds not thousands but there are
hundreds of thousands if you start
counting international airlines and if
you start looking so if you start
counting it and you just do some simple
math you realize that we're talking
about some huge amounts of data that
just gets collected by these sun sensors
every day and as i was just talking
about this is just the aviation business
then you're the same thing about power
generation you know same thing about
wind turbines renewables you know things
like those so each one of those are just
full of sensors they're just collecting
data
so
the important thing that uh becomes for
us is that you know we certainly want to
collect all the data right
but then what do we do with that data so
we can do many things with the data i
mean we can certainly make the machine
smarter right so that's one thing we
take all the data and build some sort of
intelligence in the machine now
intelligence in the machine can be built
again at two levels so to speak one can
be at the local level itself like the
machine itself is sort of self cognitive
understands what it should do right take
a few decisions autonomously without
necessarily human intervention
and by the way that is all very common
it may sound like some ai out there but
it is not its pretty common
so much so to the extent that
let me ask you a question how many of
you drive a prius here
some of you must be driving a prius i'm
pretty sure it's pretty common in the
bay area so for example a you know
pretty
sort of easily available car like prius
uses the technology called fly by wire
which is used to fly planes actually so
a lot of that you see is no more those
gears and axles actually mechanically
moving things right and there's a lot of
autonomous
work going on in terms of let's say the
battery charging
the engine is pretty smart enough to
know when it should go into the charge
mode versus when it should start you
know using the battery power and so on
so forth so why i'm saying that is that
a lot of machine intelligence can be
built locally within the machine itself
now then beyond that there is a second
dimension you know which was mentioned
about let's say the smart car company
that picked up a lot of data that what
will you do with all these tons of data
that you collect
right so that has there is a humongous
amount of opportunity there you could
basically learn a lot of things that you
may have never thought of
you would explore a lot of different
hypotheses also and figure out what
should be looked at say to make your
engine better or to do your maintenance
on time or to uh
you know whatever make it more reliable
or just you know make some decisions
without necessary human interference so
there is a ton of that which in terms of
machine intelligence and then the third
aspect of course is just the humongous
amounts of data because you know as i
mentioned there's just so much data
being collected but you've got to do the
standard things that you've got to do
with data which you've got to store it
and analyze it and move it and you know
also kind of satisfy various levels of
querying across the data set right so
there's going to be some batch long
running jobs there can be some very
instantaneous interactive type of
querying and you know so on and so forth
there
and then of course the fourth part is
the analytics which essentially is where
we are looking at just smarter
algorithms or just algorithms themselves
kind of getting smarter as you do more
there are also a few more important
things which makes the industrial
internet or you know the entire thing
that we look at ge very unique and
different from so let us say a social
networking view point is some of these
parameters like you know safety security
and determinism now why i am saying
these are so important is because
you wouldn't want to fly in a plane
where the engine kind of is quirky or
doesn't feel like behaving the way it
should be behaving right would you so
it's one of those things uh many of
these power generation units if they
don't behave as they're supposed to
behave at the right time have outages or
you know problems could actually lead to
severe amounts of loss not only monetary
loss but actually a lot of other damages
including you know perhaps uh you know
harm humans right so we cannot take a
chance there or rather let me put it
this way the amount of chances we can
take are very limited in that sense we
want the machines to behave in a
deterministic way and more so especially
when they become smart right
otherwise there's also this whole
you know
i guess the weird ai horror of machines
taking over humans right so
so you don't want them to be super smart
either you want them to be smart but you
want them to be deterministic the second
part is safety which i think also is
very important because uh
you know you don't want it's it's it's
miserable when you're let's say a social
account gets hacked
uh but you can still kind of live with
it so to speak right your twitter
account is hacked it's not really uh you
know it sure it might be damaging your
let's say credibility or profile or
something but it's not really killing
you but you know if
some of these critical systems again
because they have an impact in society
in general multiple ways if they
compromise on security it could have
huge repercussions
funny enough though um
i don't know if how many of you guys
have heard about this but you know a few
months back there was a conference up in
europe and a guy uh basically said well
i'll show you how to hack off uh plane
in flight how can you get the engine
data right now i don't how many of you
guys have heard of this
some of you must have right and he
actually demoed it he said i'll do it
right now in a very simple way and he
actually called up the call center got
some details about that flight and you
know some some things he needed but it
was funny that he could actually even
hack into that system now obviously he
was benign hacker he didn't mean to harm
anything so he didn't do anything and
sure enough of course it was a little
hyped also it was not like he was going
to actually make uh you know the engine
behave differently but having said that
the important part is even to have
access to that kind of data is risky
right and we don't want that
so
you know the security part becomes super
important
now let's get to the second part of the
story and again i'll try to rush through
it i don't want to take up too much time
here but so the second part is that most
of the machines when they were
traditionally built and the way they've
evolved is what we like to call you know
they were very kind of physics driven so
to speak in the sense that uh all the
innovation happened in the machine parts
themselves
so if you look at all these innovations
especially let's say you know the
interesting part is your aerospike story
for example so a lot of innovation
actually went in how you build that
nozzle or the spike on the top and there
was tons of years of work just around
the aerodynamics of the small parts
right and sure enough that's important i
mean machines need certain physics and
you know precision in terms of you know
the sort of machinery itself the
engineering of the machinery but having
said that i think the what we think is
that the next generation of power will
come from actually the software that
will run on those machines
and increasingly that's what is
happening in the sort of industrial
space also because you know the machine
technology is increasingly getting kind
of commoditized for example you know
maybe a few years back it was pretty
hard to build a ct scan machine but
today that technology is known so many
companies who are smart at manufacturing
could say for example you know just for
the sake of an example build that
machine so now the differentiators of
the value add really come in can you
make a smarter ct scan machine so the
scanning technology itself is kind of
done the problem is solved but can you
then get more analytics and make it
smarter make it personalized you know
the patient goes in for a scan and then
the machine knows the history of the
patient for example right that these
were all your past scans and this is
what we figured out and so i should
probably focus on more scans in this
region as opposed to a general scan
let's assume the machine does that okay
that is a lot more value adding than you
know just innovating on the machine
itself so that's the kind of second part
to that
so let me kind of jump through some of
these i'm not going to talk about this
slide let me just talk about the data
volumes um and i think i have probably
one more and i'll be done with it so you
know we always talk about the social
networks as a huge hose pipe out there
right just generating humongous amounts
of data and they are for sure i mean
there are various numbers i don't have
it off the top of my head i'm sure some
of you probably know it but i think the
amount of data that was generated from
the beginning of mankind till 2008 was
generated in the last two years or
whatever something like that uh there is
some number i think if you google for it
you'll find it on the net but it is true
actually so um so yes the amount of data
that is getting generated today is
humongous it's it's a lot and you know
social networking is one prime example
where a lot of data generated at a very
fast pace for example there's 80
gigabits per day of data generated on
twitter just as a you know sort of a
data point and in fact if you speak to
guys from twitter and from you know
facebook and other companies when these
companies were happily growing one of
the biggest challenges they had was not
analytics
it was actually about just making sure
that there are enough disks out there so
as the data was written they would
actually have some space to go for the
data to be written on literally they
would
rush there and just add some more on to
their uh you know racks out there so
make sure that there's enough space that
you could go and write and keep writing
now if you look at a ge kind of scenario
uh this is just one example it says gas
turbine that is in operationally there
and you know obviously all these
have tons of sensors
they actually generate 588 gigabytes of
data per day
just one turbine right now so we got to
be a little smart about it in the sense
that we also need to be smart in terms
of how we save the data how we compress
the data should we save all the data in
some cases it should be selective about
saving the data right so there is a lot
of other challenges that also come in
and then there is the
you know the big problem that people
sort of worry about in the big data
world is that
should you make a choice up front in
terms of what data should be saved or
should you just save everything dump it
out there and then figure out later you
know whether the data is
uh good for you to save or not
so that's uh you know that's essentially
that and this is pretty much the last
slide here which is giving you just a
sample uh you know in terms of the
amounts of data and you know how
you could essentially add value at
different levels just by analyzing the
data smartly so for example i'll just
take the aviation example again because
some of the aviation examples make good
examples i've realized so you know they
just like the i guess nice fancy
aspirational value flight has always
been one aspiration for humans i think
despite the fact that we've kind of
solved that problem um
so
now seriously i think flight has kind of
defined human science innovation so i
believe i mean when when humans crossed
sound barrier it was really bigger than
most of the things we had done right one
man reached and stepped on the moon that
was again like the thing that we had
done so yeah so going back to this whole
space flight concept many of you may may
not realize but you know small traffic
trajectory changes in a flight path
could lead to substantial variation in
terms of the amount of cost of that
flight
because
the amount of fuel consumption also
depends exactly on the wind uh you know
depending on the altitude that it flies
in and things like those there are a ton
of parameters there right uh so even if
we optimize let's say we use the
algorithms and said you know what just
the way you descend if you just change
the way you descend a little bit say in
san francisco versus the way you descend
in new york jfk
that could actually lead to substantial
amount of savings
not today we can't do that because we
don't want to get tricky with all these
flight things we don't want to run into
an accident just in order to save some
money but if we had smarter machines and
we actually had the data on time right
and we had those smart algorithms which
we built
say with past whatever 10 years of
flight or 20 years of flight data then i
think we'll be in a situation to do that
so there's a lot of you know potential
gain out there and um
beyond that there are more i guess
simpler gains but straightforward gains
where you know today and i will kind of
close on that um and maybe we'll have
more in q a but uh most of you are aware
of the fact that our world runs on
time-based maintenance
so your car goes on maintenance five
thousand miles ten thousand miles thirty
thousand miles fifty thousand miles
right there is a time-driven maintenance
uh your uh appliances uh warranties and
maintenance around time-driven
maintenance
and everything else in life is pretty
much a time driven maintenance right six
months something happens one year
something happens the same thing is in
the industry also today by the way and
what happens in the industry is that
most of these service level contracts
which could even make or break your
business are based around those
contracts whether they're actually used
or not used it's pretty much like
insurance in some sense in a sense if
you start failing all your timely driven
contracts right and they need more and
more maintenance then too bad for you
you'll probably out of business very
soon so
you know if you flip that out and just
question the whole story if you're let's
assume just take the car story since all
of us are very used to it right and we
understand that problem say at 5000
miles my car is just fine and i've been
super diligent about maintaining it well
should i still go for a maintenance does
it really make sense should i should i
not right so because we're so tuned to
it we think like yeah we should because
5000 miles how could i skip my
maintenance but the fact is what if it
was more event driven or behavior driven
or very personalized maybe your car
needed maintenance 8000 miles or 833
miles who knows right so all i'm trying
to say is that there is a lot of
opportunity in just the whole
maintenance space which is huge for a
company like ge right because a lot of
us is around maintaining these various
assets that we have
uh i think that itself is a humongous
opportunity so so anyway on that note
i'll kind of stop here i've already
exceeded you know way more i think like
maybe eighty percent of my time
but but thanks very much and more in the
q a and
over to our next speaker yeah thank you
very much
so now we have
sucantha from
from quickpay
my presentation is not that colorful you
won't see many pictures
uh
not a lot of billion dollar stories
uh i work for a small startup uh based
in san francisco called quickbay
uh we are in mobile parking and mobile
payments
i'll move this thing so i can have some
room
uh
so before uh i start has anybody heard
of this company
oh wow that's nice that's really nice uh
we are
just about two years old
and um
not a very exciting space parking i mean
it's not that exciting i generally don't
get to wear this
i'm in garages so this is my time to
wear it so i'm going to keep it on
but when we started when i started the
company i was a little
unsure i mean
my friend is a close friend as a ceo of
the company i was a little unsure
whether i would actually go into parking
space
because at the end of the day with maybe
500 million dollars at a billion dollar
business is it worth enough right
uh
today north america does 26 billion
dollars in parking
26 billion dollars in a segment that
nobody cares about
everybody parks
everybody hates it i'm sure
uh there is not not a single exciting
thing about parking that people like but
you have to do it
and there are some problems
and that's where entrepreneurs like to
go and innovate
i've been in startups majority of my
career and always
always solve really really complicated
high-end
solutions which take two years to build
this was the first one where it didn't
take that much long time to build
but interestingly enough
internet of things i actually stumbled
into it i didn't plan to i read i knew
what they were i knew what cisco was
doing i read about ge
you know exciting i you know was excited
to read those things but it just
happened that you know when we were
building a solution and looking at
ways to make things better it ended up
that those things kind of fell as a
requirement in my lap
and that's how we kind of stumbled into
it
and
this is this is the only icon or image
you'll see you won't see anymore
we don't have much
before i jump into what we do and and
how we ended up building a
internet of things device let me talk a
little bit about
what my understanding my read my
findings and there's tons of tons of
paper that's actually a fantastic paper
from somebody from cisco talking about
internet of things
beautiful projections on what what is
happening where the segment is going to
go
you know how people would be interacting
with machines with devices talking cars
talking
planes talking trains maybe
but at the end of the day the problem
that that we have to solve i mean you
guys are solving this and
my esteemed colleagues are solving it
today
is that it's essentially the growth of
data
more devices come in more components you
know smart unsmart things which you know
pump in two to two bytes a second and
some pumping in two megabytes a second
at the end of the day what ends up
happening is a lot of data gets into the
into the pipe into the into the internet
the highway
and as these things go in
somebody somebody wants to do something
about it i mean things are going in
there must be a reason why it is going
in
and that's where you know smart
companies like aerospike come with good
solution to help companies figure out
how to how to capture them how to mine
them how to be responsive in a real-time
basis
and
while while these opportunities open up
it actually helps the customers the
businesses
ask smarter things they actually would
be you know asking for a solution that
you think you want to build
so that's the segment that i am in a lot
of these solutions that we're building
are things that the customers feel that
they needed but they don't know how to
get it done
and
quickly presented an opportunity to go
and and address these elements
since uh data is uh where the business
is growing and and data is where we all
want to go capture mine figure out
value-added solutions to build and offer
our products you know through our
companies or other companies that we
work with
uh we want to figure out how uh the data
goes in
what kind of data goes in what are the
data what are the data items that we
actually want to filter read understand
and the ones that we want to just bypass
just let it flow
and uh
as uh innovation comes from the
switching the routing
the sdns the
the data storage companies uh the caches
the you know the clusters the high
availability solution at these things
come in that opens up opportunities for
entrepreneurs like me and like you guys
out there to figure out what new things
to build and how to build it and which
elements to go capture so at the end of
the day internet internet of things is
actually internet of opportunities
tremendous amount of opportunities if
you if you just drive around the silicon
valley corridor across 101 or even 280
for that matter you'll see
tons and tons of companies who are going
and capturing a small portion of it and
and launching and you know launching
products launching solutions launching
offerings which go and
address these problems and some of them
are big you know there's there's a
everybody talks about big data
we actually talk about small data there
is real small data that goes in and this
small data has a lot of money associated
with it you know everything that you
know an enterprise does
we have to deal with it whether it's
security whether it is availability
whether it is you know latency through
which things come in we have solutions
out there in the market uh where
um
when you go into an expensive hotel or
expensive building or or or areas where
there is valet you have the valet
treatment we are building these things
for average people for ordinary people
like me who can't and won't pay 75 to
serve somebody to park a car we're
building those kind of solutions we're
trying to bring those kind of
convenience and those kind of you know
simplicity in into into the space
a lot of it starts from the mobile
technology which initiates but we are
we're in you know we are building
solutions in the connected car space i
mean there's a ton of things that i can
talk about and i literally have six
minutes to go through this
as i said quick pay we are a mobile
payments mobile parking mobile payments
company
mobile payments essentially was a
byproduct of the of since we wanted
people to conveniently
start their parking session through
their mobile devices cell phones ios
devices android the blackberries the
windows mobile and so on so forth uh
making it easier demanded that we have
an integrated payment platform into the
solution
so we ended up becoming you know a
payment platform ended up building a
platform we become a consumer for it and
then
we are looking at opening up so that
others can use it but at the end of the
day what it funnels is a transaction
that is going through the system and the
transaction has a cause the cause is
sparking in this case
now why are we talking about internet of
things
when we
started doing deals with some of the
operators we sort of sit between the
b2bs and the b2cs in the world
my consumers are consumers who actually
use the solution in the mobile phone to
start the parking session but my
customers are the ones who actually host
my solution in their garages in their
facilities where parking services
offered so i kind of sit between them
kind of you know trying to make sure
both sides are happy
one side wants a lot of money the other
side is you know paying the least amount
of money so i kind of bridge that uh
segment
while we were
investigating how to make things better
in gated garage solution
we kind of stumbled upon
how we could actually solve the problem
by allowing
a little device that could sit inside
the garage inside the gate arm which
nobody looks at it's rusty it's dusty
you know there's cobwebs in there i've
done that so i know it
uh but what ends up happening is that
there's a little sensor which sits in
there that we build and this sensor
keeps on constantly monitoring what's
happening
who gets in who gets out at what time
and as we started collecting the
information this whole thing dawned upon
us we don't really need an enterprise
300 000 analytic system to analyze what
is happening in the garage
through the device that we are
monitoring and the data that we're
collecting on a real-time basis we can
actually go and tell a parking facility
or an operator how many cars are in at
any point of time
and based on what they're doing at 12
o'clock on every tuesday how many more
can be brought in
and that solution
is goldmine for them
they have no way to know these things
there are human beings which are doing
that at four hour interval and 12 hour
intervals
so we actually made that thing happen in
real life
and automated so for from my point of
view internet of things is actually
these little small things
which brings in so much convenience and
so much value from a customer's point of
view customers being the operator
customer being me as a customer
i could actually while driving on 101
in palo alto open up my mobile phone
which i shouldn't be doing my wife would
be doing that since i'll be driving
and she can locate where we are going to
go
right she can locate but she doesn't
drive when i drive she
when when when i open up them she'll
open up the mobile phone she'll locate
where we're going to go
and
20 minutes 30 minutes before i go there
she can actually book my parking
so i'm not running on 11th and 12th and
folsom in howard locating a parking spot
if i have to go pitch to a vc
over there i'll be on time
if i have to close a deal i don't have
to apologize why i'm 15 minutes late
so these are simple things but impacts
most of us on a daily basis
and
some really exciting stuff that actually
comes out as byproduct of this
is as these data gets collected in
we can predict at any route
what is the traffic load that is going
to happen over there
which means
we can tell ahead of time
don't take the 11th street exit because
in the next 15 minutes it's going to be
jammed up with 2 000 cars backed up
this is uh i mean these are things this
is this is a byproduct of what internet
of things is
simple easy but it can solve so much so
many problems if anybody's done this
thing i do it my cities my office is in
the city i live down south
and
sometimes it is an hour and a half
sometimes it's two hours there is no way
to predict this
and this is living in silicon valley uh
the best technologies of the world the
best you know consumption of
technologies of the world and i'm still
sitting over there honking and listening
to my music
because i can't get there and i have no
idea how to solve the problem
so these are some of some of the
innovations that internet of things can
actually solve
and the only reason i'm talking about is
not because we are so super cool about
it
these opportunities do exist
the amount of data that all these smart
devices the ge devices the cisco
switches cisco has you know deals going
on with city operators where they're
collecting all these feed and
distributing it
you know whether it is the government
agencies or the private agencies out
there they are funneling this data out
there
there is tons of opportunities for
people to go and figure out how to
innovate in the space
i have 37 seconds left
uh
again going back to the world of
opportunities i mean
the amount of data that you know these
solutions are collecting these solution
are actually putting into the system
uh internet being a pipe we just have to
figure out how to consume and what to
consume and there are great solutions
out there that that will make you you
know do
make the selection help you do the
choices
uh internet of things is actually
entered into opportunities at least for
me and i'm sure you guys are you know
excited about looking at new things to
build in that space thank you
uh thanks a lot sukanta and thanks to
all of our panelists for uh giving us a
such a varied perspective
so we would like to open it now to all
of you
okay rest your hand
it's great to first
the
billiard trillion dollar plans from
cisco and ge
so
the the plans which you have is because
you guys have
are closer to the data you guys have
access to the data which which
which the data analytics can be run upon
and where the algorithms can be put in
place to bring the meaningful or
actionable insights
so my question is as you are building
the empire to hire people and to and to
go in this space
people in this room are also some
entrepreneurs out here or they want to
also participate in this in this whole
way of internet of things
will can there be an opportunity where
where the data as it is
proprietary or residential within within
the
enterprises can be
exposed
the privacy can be can be removed i mean
the privacy information can be removed
but it can be exposed and small
entrepreneurs can
get that data and can run and can do
more innovative algorithms on it and we
all can be part of the same same
internet of things wave and can build
more innovative solutions can there be a
possibility like that
i i can take this so we
absolutely the answer is yes if you look
at a smart city
architecture a smart city combines
transportation healthcare education all
those all those datas are coming what
you will see is that there will be a new
uh a broker or exchange information
exchange or broker that will that will
be responsible for the privacy and the
policy and what information goes to what
give you an example in the healthcare
you have so many stakeholders you have
your insurance
company you have your pharmacy you have
your general practitioner you have even
your um your own own private uh
uh
thing so your own social circle so the
who gets what information uh is got to
be very careful same thing for the uh
traffic i mean if you look at
transportation there is auto oems who
wants to do about diagnostics there are
people about traffic management there is
about
the good driver behavior like
progressives of the world so they all
need canned information and they will be
building on that but what it requires is
as you collect all this information i
believe that there will be a a different
players that have to come and play this
mediator or broker service and they will
be hold accountable for privacies
uh and they will have to figure out what
information is um shared and not shared
and how it is shed
so just to add um we have two customers
uh ones in the bay area called
blue kai another one in excellent in new
york and in the advertising and
behavioral space they are exchanges
exactly like what we're talking about so
these are data management platforms in
advertising parlance and as an
entrepreneur you can hook up with these
guys and you can say i want to open an
account with you and when i see this
particular cookie i want to know the
audience information about it right now
i want to know some
randomized and aggregate information
about their last behavior etc um so
we're already seeing this in the
internet of people where there are these
brokers they're not household names is
the interesting thing right you do have
to you know i don't know if there is one
yet for parking right but uh they're
gonna happen these information exchanges
they already exist in advertising and
behavior
i believe that they're going to happen
with internet of things as well they
have to
so i can i can just add another
dimension to it not to
just keep going with that same question
but uh so for a company like ge
we certainly are looking at a whole
partner ecosystem
there is no way on earth that we can
build the entire end-to-end industrial
internet alone all by ourselves
for example
our sets of you know customers vendors
suppliers
um you know
the companies that basically do let's
say maintenance on our behalf and
everybody else who was some sort of
service provider would certainly be part
of the story so that that is definitely
there
i think the other part is i think you
mentioned more in terms of individuals i
think that was probably a question in
terms of can individuals actually use
that data and do something with it
i don't know if we will do anything like
that considering that we are a very
business to business type of an
organization so i don't know if it's
really relevant for us there uh there
potentially may be cases where it gets
relevant especially with the you know
things where we get closer to the
consumer space but i don't even know
about that i don't believe that's
anywhere
happening immediately
what we're doing though apart from that
is that at least in the bay area so
the other reason just to mention why did
you even set up the center in bay area
and why that is relevant is because
there is an important ecosystem here
where people are learning from each
other so you know just for example big
data i mean if you look at the number of
big data companies and the various
offshoots of you know the original
things that kind of you know emerged
from those google papers and things done
at yahoo with hadoop you know how things
have gone so far and there are so many
different companies you know that have
emerged out of that small little humble
beginnings
is that because people all around here
are kind of learning from each other and
employees are kind of moving companies
also taking that knowledge along with
them so uh that is definitely going to
happen we certainly want to participate
in that some of you may have heard of
some of the investment decisions that g
made recently for example we uh took a
stake in pivotal so you know which is a
player like aerospike so to speak um you
know also solving the big greater
problem in their own way and i believe
that more of that will happen i mean i
don't know for sure but yeah uh that
kind of participation would continue to
happen and that i think would not only
happen with secondly ge but i'm pretty
sure that every other play in the
segment would look at either partnering
or investing or doing something or the
other in the space so it's likely to
happen yeah it's a short answer thank
you
yes my name is miguel cobo i'm working
for erickson the swedish multinational i
would say as an analogy to what you said
50 of the calls in north america mobile
calls come through our systems
so we're coming from the telecom world
um
more reflection
three years ago we
we initiated a study on internet of
things we wanted to
really understand an outside outside in
view of this phenomena
i read the report from cisco
more than 11 exabyte of
data
on the mobile
that will be generated for mobile data
traffic per month
which for those who don't know it's an
exabyte is 18 zeros so it's a lot of
data and i we realized that
the industry is taking for granted a lot
of things
and there are some basic
prerequisite that needs to be fixed
before we see the explosion of revenues
first how we're going to fix the revenue
sharing between those who own the
networks
and that need to pay for the
infrastructure for that data to go
across
that is an important factor
the other one is the price of the
sensors because
things could be anything right the car
is easy to manage
but i've seen i've see we have seen
companies that even put some sensor in
the pill that you digest right here
so
the price of those sensors needs to be
cents or a cent to really make that
and then we realize also that sooner or
later we will need to have identity
management of things
we'll have to create a wikipedia of
things we need to create some kind of
linkedin of things
right because of course where will be
the values on the connectivity of
non-obvious
or not trivial thing
right
and as i say i was more
wanted to know what was your opinion
about at least that was our findings and
we we noticed that it will take some
time before we can see this huge amount
of money that in some reports are
reflected but
these are important factors and finally
also the
the authentication right not only that
we need to identify that those things
says the right thing
right
as information but also those things
should be able to authenticate systems
that are asking them information because
of fraud and everything anyway just a
reflection
any comments on them
i mean i i can i can definitely take a
shot at it i think first of all i think
i alluded that
we have silos today in the vertical
and in the future which could be
somewhere around 2020 where i called a
connected society which is so which is
connecting things and people
and op and objects and so on so that is
that is what you're talking about where
everything comes to so i think that is
that timing is more
uh it might be somewhere after 2018 2020
that's when it will be because right now
the industry is busy in in vertical
vertically connecting their own and
solving their own problem
and then the next
opportunity is going to be when you do
mash up of this different things they
are not supposed to talk to each other
the network analytics is not supposed to
talk to date device analytics that's not
supposed to talk to user data analytics
now when you mesh this three-dimensional
stuff together you create a new type of
application that we have not thought
about today most of those things are
linear on the same level we have we can
do network analytics great someone you
know google can do great user data
analytics and so on what's happening
when you start mashing all those things
new opportunities comes around
talking about security
it's uh it's a very important that
mutual authentication identity identity
management i don't know whether i know
you're with ericsson i don't know
whether the sim is the answer to many of
those
yes
yeah well then you have the operators uh
really getting scared whether they lose
control of the subscriber or not so
there are some there's some emotional
aspects and and financial aspects of
soft sim and the impact on roaming and
so on so so uh but definitely it's going
towards ecm and
and that direction but the
the authentication the security angle
is is very important identity management
is is going to be a very key and this is
device identity management
um so those are that's why i alluded
that we have a specific group now
looking into security which is not id
security
and that's what we're calling an
internet security which means
intelligent and intelligent objects
sometimes
you don't have ip address i know we are
calling internet of things but rfid has
ip address
really no right so rfid reader has so
but how how do you authenticate how does
a sensor in an oil pipe
where you want to know that if the pipe
temperature has gone more than 50
degrees how do you make sure that a
rogue sensor is not giving a wrong
information and you're making those
unintelligent decisions so uh those are
i think the securities is going to be i
think people who work on security by the
way good news i think uh the industries
has always loved you guys you always
have been on top but this is another
huge opportunity which is a security for
internet of things and that's a huge
opportunity out there
so just to add to that small bit i mean
i
this is not a company viewpoint or
anything but just my personal viewpoint
isn't that you have to realize that
i think a lot of this would happen for
sure because there is a lot of
opportunity as you know a friend from
quickpay was saying so the opportunity
itself might drive some innovation as
always happens
but i think beyond that if you just
historically go back and look at it and
this is actually read somewhere some
kind of stealing of a book that i read
the idea that most big innovations or
big things happen when three things
align
and i think if i remember that correctly
is
good economy
uh fair competition
and uh critical mass
and i think that's what has led all
along uh for then three things kind of
align
then most big turning points happen
that's when you know the space wars
happened that's when internet boomed
many of these happen on times when
somehow you know all three have to match
so now if you look at it right now and
you're trying to map good economy i
think hopefully we'll see good economy
in future we've probably seen the bottom
out so
i'm not hoping we keep going bottoming
out further
competition i think yeah there's a fair
bit of competition coming up with all
these investments and people wanting to
gain something out of those and also all
the other innovation that's going on so
that will generate some competition
among big small and all kinds of players
and then the third one is critical mass
which time will tell how soon the
critical mass will happen i think the
only thing that we have learned over the
years is that the amount of time it
takes to generate critical mass is just
rapidly decreasing
so you know if you start looking at
again innovation cycles it took x number
of years from you know
aviation technology or automobile
technology whatever to evolve and then
now if you start looking at current
technological trends including
all the stuff that's happened in the
world of mobile uh and smartphones
especially that's a great indication
right it's now reduced down to even less
than three months
right i mean
samsung comes out with four models every
year i think these days
not even once in a year so
just just my two cents to that
i i'd like to add one more point over
there specifically on the
uh on the big dollars being quoted out
there i think
given given the traditional approach of
quoting big market revenue generation i
did that i said 26 billion dollars
but what we are seeing today is a lot of
it is cross-pollination of data going
from one segment to another for instance
i mean i think there was a gentleman who
was asking about
can we collect data can we innovate
sfmta if you go over there
a lot of the information is actually
freely available
so cities are making that movement right
that allows you to build a solution for
advertisement for instance which will
tell you
in this particular location how many
newcomers come in
you can build an application over there
and go and go sell
go fight groupon and the space that they
could not innovate
right so i think i think those kind of
cross-pollination will happen
so you will see the dollars kind of
spray over there wouldn't be the
classical devices and the systems and
the switches that were being sold
but cross-pollination of information
going from one segment to another
i mean there are solution out there that
as you're driving
your information is being pumped in
through the networks
my point is that
the success that you that you have on
the company is because you own those
sensors
right
you don't depend on second source
your information your business of the
accuracy of your sensors correct
that's not true
there are some of the information that
we collect yes are sensors which are
installed by the city
built by somebody else fine but if those
sensors send wrong information your
business you're out of business that's
what i'm trying to say so without
creating infrastructure of validating
the source validating that the
the sensor
are truly sending the right information
so you need to do much more than just
collect the data you need to validate
that your source
says the truth that's correct right
and and then again this exabytes of data
that infrastructure which cisco or
ericsson will sell
well if we are not able to connect
part of the revenue sharing to those who
are transporting that information even
though it's boring as you said yep yep
there will not be any internet of things
that's all what i'm trying to say as a
reflection
so just to share one
vignette from the advertising space and
again i'm sure the advertising space
doesn't you know if you get one sensor
glitch no babies die uh i like that kind
of space um but
there are techniques that do not require
cryptography and do not require that
kind of analog you can do it in other
ways right so in advertising what you
look for is you look for spurious
patterns now how do you tell a black
swan from a spurious pattern is an
interesting process problem in signal
processing uh but you do need to figure
out where the robots are where the
scanners are
and where essentially fraud detection is
happening within the internet in order
to ignore those patterns um so they're
just saying there are some other uh ways
besides sort of crypto secure
technologies
absolutely
well well taken
dave shields our consultant zurich
switzerland um
three points then i think the last
speaker touched on some of them briefly
tangentially first one relates to
intellectual property in such
dense interconnected interdependent
nodes and networks
who's going to own the integ
intellectual property generated or
implicitly will every participant give a
free license to everyone else that's one
thing
second thing is
what happens about product liability and
warranty and so on in such dense
interconnection
who's going to be liable for what
the third question is
if everybody's in a node or in a network
and somebody doesn't like it after a
while and they pull out causing
consequential losses to the other
parties will the lawyers have a field
day
are you a lawyer sir
just checking
an economist
close enough
well very interesting question i don't
know if any of our panelists is ready to
tackle that
i'll take a shot at it because we see
some of this in advertising today um the
the chains of sort of liability and
control and ownership are actually kind
of common sense in a lot of ways um this
the the only hard part is uh if you own
a sensor uh you sort of feel that you
have uh sort of first rights and
ownership of the generation of that
sensor uh and usually you have some
rights to place it um created by some
you like right so if you're i was
working in a company called eye control
which is now created the home automation
system uh adt pulse and so adt when they
install a system they believe they have
some ownership created by the the
installation guide that says you know we
can do x y with your data uh the
analysis that gets created is done by
whoever's done doing the analysis right
so you've got those sensors created then
you've got the ip created by those
analysis folks um part of the business
driver of internet of things is going to
be selling those analysis right when
quickpay uh uh opens up apis because now
they can not only uh uh they have their
own data and they're able to sort of do
things with that data they enable an
entrepreneur well i mean it's pretty
clear you know quick pay maybe did some
analysis or they're selling raw sensor
data for less someone else creates an
analysis for it
um you know we've worked this out within
the advertising space and it's actually
not that big a deal now the liability
problems i don't know that's that's hard
but once you know ownership maybe you
know a liability
so um i would like to say something
around the reliability i i want to avoid
the liability
if you don't mind
so what we are seeing in the industry
and and that is coming down is a new
consumption model
and and i want to share with you
example of how
the
risk mitigation and the reliability is
is passed on from
you know the traditional way where you
have the entitlement to the people who
are making it it started in the in the
aviation industry where the concept is
power by hour
so you pay for the hour of operation and
the and the vendor is responsible for
the uptime
so and and that wasn't a very expensive
jet engines and so on now that has
trickled down even to the lighting pole
working with this uh famous
lighting pole company in netherlands
uh you have to figure out who it is
they put light bulbs uh very well known
has been around for a long long time
typically i'll give you an example
what's happening with city a light pole
typically cost around 10 000 euro for
european europeans out there
for physical labor and whole
installation per light pole is 10 000
euros now the cities don't have that
much money anymore
and you i don't know if you drive across
europe you'll see some places uh the
roads are lit up some places is dark
it's based on the ability of each city
each
er
and their affordability what has
happened is now that's been turned
around now the vendor was who is
building the light and the light poles
are responsible for putting it in the
ground and is sold as lighting as a
service
and cities are paying per per month
which is much more easier instead of
paying 10 000 euro per light pole so
they can use that money for health care
education other places
what it also means is the people who are
making those equipment are responsible
for their uptime so they're doing even
better
by the way example when i was studying
at university in netherlands
and
my professors were from those industries
and the fluorescent light was invented
we had to do what is called a quality of
service which means make sure that light
don't last too long because we want
people to buy go and buy again so there
was a there was a so we were optimizing
the product for
our revenue because that's the way we
had the revenue your light has to go
down you have to go buy a new one
when you change the consumption model
which is as a service
and now the responsibility turn around
so now we are making much more greener
much reliable and it's uptime and there
is a sla around it so i think i think
those those changes of consumption
models are also going to drive the
people who builds the infrastructure
builds those things are going to be part
of the owner
will have the
responsibility
thank
you
thank you uh is it working
i can just just talk louder
is it better
no it's the same
hurry up
you guys can hear me i hear you yeah uh
godfrey chuba from uh infinite's
research uh tech analysts uh covering
machine to machine iot and things like
that um
i actually have many questions so i'm
just gonna pick one uh and maybe kind of
steer the discussion a little bit more
to the business model side of things in
terms of how we can actually from an
economic standpoint drive adoption of
iot
um
taking the smart city as an example
because i think the panelists can all
talk to uh different aspects of it is
you know so we've been looking at the
smart cities uh various initiatives
around the world talk to some of the
constituencies there and
i mean obviously it's a very challenging
process a lot of players involved a lot
of bureaucracy to deal with
ultimately to try and push it forward
you need real economic drivers to get
the cities really thinking we can do
this and we can pay for it it's not just
going to come out of tax dollars
one of the things that have come out is
parking
actually could be one of the killer
applications for it so i'm just curious
from the panel standpoint what other
examples can you cite you know
especially at cisco
in terms of business models that are
helping drive
you know you provide some examples
already but business models can drive
for example the smart city what
applications
services can help justify the investment
so it's not just coming out of tax
dollars
so uh i'll start and then please join me
so cities have cios i think i think you
may i don't know many people know that
even san jose has a cio and he's a very
progressive guy fantastic guy but uh so
cities are looking you know traditional
way is
um we did a parking meter in san mateo
and san francisco which
we paid for it
because the city didn't have the money
but uh
that's okay you know it's we are
incubating internet of things and that's
great examples but
some of the city cios are looking so you
have to find a new way of of monetizing
now you will be surprised that
cities get tax dollar by where you live
right
so there is a competition for skilled
workers to be in san jose rather than in
some other counties so cities will be
competing with each other that's the new
economy we're going to go because when
you have internet of things and when you
have this kind of broadband capability
you will have a lot of the example was
mentioned here what was done by human is
now automated
so so you will so the skilled workers
you need to attract the skilled workers
you need to attract the business one of
the way san jose is looking at san jose
cio is looking at is to provide that
broadband in the city as
automatically for the businesses
hopefully the business will come the the
they will attract the skill workers and
that will attract the businesses to come
so the broadband is by default and they
get the revenue through the taxation
because businesses happen they get tax
dollars so it's a indirect model of of
really funding a city rather than
upfront okay who's gonna pawn you up
let's put it and uh so you have to
make some bets and and that's how you
would see
some of the cities doing it and as it
becomes more successful uh others will
follow quick follow on that uh has cisco
done some studies to actually put some
numbers behind that maybe commission it
with some professors or something
and the reason i'm motivated to ask that
question is it's funny you mentioned cio
so i'm actually chairing a panel of cios
on smart cities in shanghai in three
weeks
so cisco has some data
well we have good examples of cios we
don't have i mean we are always looking
at uh chicago cio and san jose some of
the ones who are progressive in in in
their way to innovate their cities and
how to attract talent
um there is a there is a
and and then talent attracts also
businesses
so uh
yeah
and and then you have to do upfront and
and there also don't forget that there
is a also an another model emerging
which is a public private partnership
and that is also another another way
where cities can
uh have to figure out you know
how to have this uh pub sub or publix
and private um uh
sorry public private uh partnership to
do a lot of a lot of the things in
europe 33 of the roads are uh tall roads
and and that's a public private uh
partnership so you could see major
infrastructure
uh of that magnitude to be following
some some type of model like that
but i'm not aware of this uh
of we have done i we don't have i don't
think we have a
study of that one but uh
i think it's something for an economics
professor to look at retention of
workforce and things like that
yeah that's a good one
yeah good one
so just a sort of uh
slight diversion to your question
actually so i think you're absolutely
right there is a lot of impact on the
smart city stuff and this is i'm not
even talking much as my ge hat on right
now because you know there is a smart
city initiative that gu will participate
in but i'm not even aware of those
details so i have no rise to speak about
it but
i'm just seeing from just general trends
that
if you take that one step further and
look at just agencies so what i mean by
county is you know state governments and
so on so forth
there are actually three or four
opportunities that i think are biggest
in terms of
uh just monetary value
uh one huge area is just energy
consumption
so for example if you look at it smart
meter has created both a lot of
excitement and also a lot of opposition
because some people also feel that it
kind of
uh you know enters into the whole
privacy realm and you know you get
uh you know sort of penalized for
certain kinds of behavior right but
having said that you know the whole
energy consumption is going to be a
massive segment
along with energy there is also the
other utilities optimization so to speak
water something is mundane as garbage
collection
you know many of these the cities have
actually been struggling with it if you
just look at the city budgets and most
of the city budgets actually available
online these days you can actually go
and look at all the bay area cities what
is the largest spending right you will
see that most of them are actually
struggling in these areas for example a
lot of these cities have been working
around can we collect garbage once in 15
days instead of every five days and
things like those you might think like
they're totally inconsequential but you
know they really impact the whole
where the city can actually pay its
police force and have its fire guys on
board or let them go it's pretty much
like boils down those kind of answers so
i think that a lot of
data around those which may not
necessarily be the typical
quintessential smart city but just
simply having data analytics around
those
is going to be a huge deal
the other segment that has gained some
interesting traction in cities like new
york and portland and some others is
just people participation in the city so
for example you know most of the cities
especially the largest cities i'm sure
san francisco has but i'm not sure but
they have a lot of helplines that just
help people uh with day-to-day things uh
essentially they're like the 311 numbers
right that you can call up for city
support lines many of these cities spent
millions of dollars just staffing people
providing support providing answers
around 3-1-1
some cities have taken proactive measure
of just providing an online interface to
begin with some other cities have come
up with things like mobile apps where
you can take pictures of potholes or
broken signs and actually just send them
to the cities and they then follow up on
those
simple measures like that have saved
lots of money to the cities um there's a
classic case not to kind of drag on this
but that i read was
apparently some district in portland
there was a part of the business
district in portland
that was suffering a lot because
essentially what would happen is that
there would be a ton of traffic jam
around that in specific times of the day
and so nobody would want to go there and
that's where most of the commercial
areas also were by commercial i mean
retail and you know boutique stores and
stuff like that so they were really
seeing a decline in the whole retail
segment nothing to do with the product
or the economy which is that there was
too much traffic and nobody wanted to be
seen around there right and also this
comes in back with our friends problem
of parking because people won't find
parking and it's just a pain and they
wouldn't want to be there
and
so a lot of people send that feedback
and what the city did was they ran a lot
of polls from what i remember just
asking people who lived in that segment
and the way i think you could get back
is again through your mobile phones when
you were there in that street that's the
only way your poll was counted or
something so they actually wanted to
hear from people not just
doing some armchair thinking but
actually on the street there and facing
some trouble and finally they came up
with the conclusion that the best way to
solve this problem is just block that
road off and
they converted that whole patch into
just a bike lane or something like that
that's the call they took so you had to
park like a few blocks away and only if
you were walking on a bike lane and
after that that whole district saw like
a humongous increase in the whole retail
story so i'm just saying they would have
probably never learned that if they were
going the orthodox way so so there are
opportunities like that to learn yeah
i have a two part question first
question is for all the panel members
what are the three
use cases or products you see both on
the consumer as well as the enterprise
space in the next 24 to 36 months
the second question is for ge and cisco
members
if you look at the big data evolution
and explosion happen since yahoo and
google published
basically their r d projects as a white
paper
if there is any new technologies which
is evolving there is ge and cisco going
to publish that white paper well in
advance so that a lot of startups
can evolve around that
yeah the three use cases are products on
the consumer-ended enterprise space for
the next 24 and 36
so i'll you go with the first b2b the
enterprise space right
and then and the cons you know cisco uh
consumer you probably saw seen our flip
departure from flip and linksys
but uh i will try to take a shot that
won't be a cisco viewpoint in that sense
that will be my personal viewpoint but
in terms of enterprise honestly
um
we're following the money
right it's following the money where we
are making the biggest impact
um
oil well
rig in a box
right it's not easy if you look at oil
oil extraction there are about you know
throwing numbers let me tell you a
number 10
terabytes of data is collected as you're
drilling the oil sensors
and typically they are located in in
some parts where some people are not
welcomed or it is very difficult for you
to have a lot of people over there so
you're collecting all this information
and you need to be today you know your
back hole often is a satellite link
a very narrow band satellite link so you
cannot send all those terabytes of of
data back to analyze and understand
which way to move your sensors so they
are they are physical tapes they are
sent by helicopters and your your oil
well is uh is stationary for three weeks
and then it get analyzed in amsterdam or
in houston and then it's sent back and
then they have the next
way of doing things
so what what they need is something that
runs analytics at the location and makes
a lot of the decisions filters out
throws 98 percent of the data which are
not relevant
that's the reality in oil well 98 of the
data are not relevant that's that that
specific information that you need so
you need to do quick analytics and be
able to make those decision and the
narrowband satellite link should be
enough to get you
going why am i saying that is big
because you know that oil oil companies
make a lot of money and and and they are
measured by their oil reserves now if
they have if they can reduce three weeks
of downtime every time
the tape runs out that makes a huge
impact so they are willing to do uh you
know a lot of things with us at big
dollars so that's one area
the the second one would be
from from our perspective is the
is the
industrial plants
manufacturing plants if you look at the
manufacturing plants you have equipment
from siemens you have from ge you have
from rockwell and all those they have
all their legacy protocols because
that's how those industries came from
and they talk among themselves but they
don't talk to each other
so you need a a and something that will
equalize so that you have the total view
of the plant what is happening on the ge
islands siemens islands and rockwell
islands and they can talk to each other
and coming over to an ethernet ip based
network from profinet
from uh or in the oil scada or profibus
and so on
to an ethernet ip or in the vehicle can
bus
so that that itself is for us
looks like the world of frame relay isdn
atm to ip we see a similar thing that
will happen in the industrial automation
where we call this operational
technology coming to ethernet ip that's
a big
uh task one of the key differentiator is
the deterministic ethernet which my
colleague from ge talked about because
we knew those protocol existed for a
reason and as we move to ethernet ip we
have to assure that the that the
reliability of those ethernet is
matching what what those protocols is so
there is a huge investment and someone
talks talked about stuxnet those are
very important as you now make those
plant which were supposed to be isolated
as you make them connected to the world
the level of security
that is needed and and the connectivity
over there is a huge huge area and this
goes for both deterministic wired
network and deterministic wireless which
is even tougher
huge opportunity on deterministic
wireless whether it is mining oil and
gas or manufacturing plants so those are
some of the area and the third one would
be in the transportation whether it's
along the
roadside equipments these are along
connected rail connected road collecting
all those information these
infrastructures are put will be put out
there for 15 20 years
so the the revenue generation from our
point of view both for the
infrastructure as well as for the
end-to-end system is huge that those are
the b2b angle and b2c
uh i don't know i don't know three but
the one that we are or one or two that
we are looking at
is around the
home automation
and we have something with it connected
live
and and we want to see how we can
replicate that this is around
aggregating all your zigbee bluetooth
all those things into one hub
at home and then providing you that
control and uh health and wellness
in the healthcare
so um i'll i'll pass it on okay sure so
um thank you so let me actually take the
second part of the question i'll skip
the first part i really don't have any
comments on that um and i'd probably
want you know the other panelists also
to jump in on the second part so if i
understood the question correctly you
are talking about the evolution that's
happening in the big data space and you
know what are we doing and as and when
we are ready with something which is
breakthrough would we be sharing with
the world in some sense um so i would
make it just a larger uh
you know sort of question here so in the
big data space
there's a ton of excitement today um you
know our hosts aerospike has got a story
and you know like i mentioned a few
companies and ourselves there is a lot
of story essentially right here in the
bay area that's emerging in the big data
space now what is happening is that uh
if you uh just kind of loop back
uh you have to understand that a lot of
the excitement in the big data space
uh happened really in the distributed
computing world so i'm really putting on
my tech hat for a few minutes and just
bringing in all the you know nosql and
big data experience that i have and i'm
just trying to speak from that
standpoint that a lot of this happened
in the distributed computing space so
when you saw those papers in much from
google uh they were really trying to
tell a story of how they solved uh
at scale problem from a distributed
computing standpoint so i'm talking
about all those papers you know the
about let's say you know the chubby or
big table or gfs and all those things
which kind of spurred this whole big
data excitement right and then everyone
knows now they've become legendary those
stories but you know when
uh you know essentially
what has become uh now lucian and stuff
like that but when natch was trying to
solve the same problem uh and then there
were other companies also but cosmics
was trying to build its own um you know
sort of big data platform they all took
inspiration from google and kind of
reinvented the wheel in some sense but
obviously there was no publicly
available wheel so they invented a
publicly available free open source
wheel out there
and it was all great and a lot of that
happened from i think from 2006 to about
in 2009-2010
actually was to my mind
one of the biggest
sort of turning points in this whole
scalable
large data space let's put it that way
right so we started seeing a ton of
different nosql companies emerge and
nosql is actually a very weird and
you know
misused term but because nosql
essentially means anything that was not
sql it's technically it was not sequel
but not relational if you think about it
right
but a lot of different platforms emerged
and now if you look at it i think
there's a lot of evolution that has gone
from just managing high throughput and
large volumes
to going back to what the database guys
have done over the years so if you think
about it all the database guys have
spent the last 20 years 25 years
innovating around query processing
around optimizers around
columnar formats around uh
you know olap versus oltp that's where
all the work has happened right and
there are a ton of great products in
that whole space right from standard
good old relational databases to you
know a lot of the data warehousing type
of solutions and so forth and lot of
that has come into the big data world
so if you look at it for example today a
lot of the innovation that's happening
in terms of how do we query faster can
we do something better than mapreduce
let's say which is the classic thing
that has been a quest for a few
companies and you see innovation from
say something like hawk that pivotal is
trying to build or impala that you know
friends at cloudera are building uh
they're basically trying to go back to
basically writing a
a query engine if you think of it if you
if you get down to the crux of it what
are they actually inventing they are
writing a query engine they're writing a
statistics based optimizer right all of
these things that the database guys have
been writing for the last 20 years and
many of you guys have in this field so
you can probably kind of speak to that
and so a lot of that optimization is
happening
the other thing that is happening is
this whole element of real time
now real time itself is a pretty tricky
term um
you know in my sort of past life so to
speak i spent a lot of
time
building very real-time applications for
the financial service world you know
and that time real time really meant
not even like milliseconds milliseconds
was too much because you could lose too
much money not for any other reason and
so there was a lot of optimization at
that point in time just simply around
getting data faster
and you know all those event stream esp
type of technology emerged in that world
right a lot of events stream processing
some of that is being brought back into
the distributed world because when we
were talking about esp sure we were
talking about speed but we're not
talking about volume of data and speed
we're talking about small volumes of
data but just focusing on speed on
optimizing bandwidth on optimizing you
know basically inverting the querying
process you know put a filter on data
through it that kind of story right now
when you take the big data space you
can't technically do that it's too hard
especially if you're trying to run that
through
multiple gigabytes terabytes and forget
petabytes petabytes is too much it's
easier to speak about petabytes you know
it's very hard to deal with petabytes
let me just say that i don't know how
many if you dealt with petabytes of data
i mean that yeah so it takes it takes a
while just to copy petabytes right just
to even copy a petabyte of data from
drive to drive it takes a long time
right just so i'm just saying like it's
easier to say about that i'm saying
managing throughputs at multiple
terabytes or petabytes is a totally
different beast
just even trying to manage that with
data just just move that much data just
copy that much data is a humongous
problem
and i think that problem was solved with
this whole hadoop evolution so to speak
at least it was solved to an extent
where it became bearable right with this
whole distributed hdfs file system it
said okay you know what don't worry
about the size throw it in and let
horizontal scaling just solve the
problem so anyway long story short do
not want to keep rambling on this but i
think there is a ton of innovation
happening a lot of exciting stuff around
querying optimization real time lots of
things that are going to happen in the
big data space a lot of that is
happening from you know various small to
large companies in the bay area uh we
have our own story we are trying to play
in that one story along with extending
products adding things building things
of our own
for example we have a huge interest in
time series data because ultimately if
you think of all the sensor data
everything is time series data if you
think about it right there's a time
point there's some value and then there
is some sort of attack sorry
so anyway so yeah you'll see a lot of
innovation there
one one quick things on that one there's
a network approach to the data as well
and uh as a
in cisco we're looking okay
the
uh you know ge talked about real time
you cannot assume that you do something
and something gets computed in the cloud
and comes back in real time honestly
so when you put those challenges
scalability bandwidth requirement real
time then you would come to a different
type of network architecture even
analytics you will come to a different
architecture so we come we have
concluded that we needed a hierarchical
architecture for analytics so analytics
at the edge close to the device is
different from analytics in the cloud
but also means that the networking role
has to change if we have to make our
service provider if we have to make our
customer uh profitable we cannot have
all the data pass through so what we are
we what we have uh started a concept of
and we are productizing is called fork
computing
you know you have the cloud up there
and the fog is more close to so so this
is this by the way fog doesn't have any
meaning but it's really the fog
if you are if you're in a golden gate
bridge and you know the fog comes so fog
computing is a mini cloud computing in
terms of compute network and storage and
a middleware that does the red resource
management across the peers so if a edge
device is
running out of capacity it can out it
can so it can point to the peering
fog device for it to do so we will see
those kind of architecture come to solve
this petabyte and zetabytes of data
because otherwise the backhaul and the
latency and the real time all those
things cannot be solved
so yeah i just want sukhant and brian to
to answer briefly it's nine o'clock
already obviously of a very fascinating
topic
and we will have to stop after that so
yes just go ahead
okay so uh one thing that we face right
now uh opportunity wise beyond parking
and beyond some of the validation
concepts and stuff like that
is essentially the real time aspect of
data a lot of information is out there
you can collect real time and you can
localize it
as if you want to go build something of
your own there is a lot of
infrastructure out there that gives you
the data that you're not going to get
from the traditional enterprise
that you can get now
and you can get that filtered
so if you're looking at opportunities
like look at that because we do get that
you know thing and being a small startup
we can do all it in all of this
so i i meet people you know lots of
people ask about what they could do
around the around the french that's
where money is happening
the real money it may be small but it
can be repeated and if you go build
these things focused on local areas you
can build a successful business and and
you know kind of replicate it in
multiple successful areas
um so
is anyone out there using storm apache
storm yet
yeah a couple things uh so uh we're
going to be hosting the uh storm uh
users group here uh in this building i
think it's what's the 26th monika
24th thank you
so ted dunning of mapr
also an nea company like us is going to
be talking about real-time processing
i'm very excited about storm we're
looking at it very strongly here as a
real-time database company because it it
forms a great interconnect pattern
we're hearing a lot of our customers
using storm and the storm processing
system you need a level of reliability
if you're doing trident for example for
um for actually keeping track of uh
message reliability so uh we're going to
be
thinking and working a lot with the
storm community in that so consider
coming out uh to hear uh to ted dunning
uh talk about what matt barr is doing
and some of the real-time use cases that
they have what
24th
24th and so it's on meetup.com thank you
very much to our panelists for a
fascinating
discussion
thanks to all of you for being here and
keeping the discussion lively
and
we are all excited about a glimpse into
the future
so thanks a lot